welcome to an episode of get close i'm
your co-host gio and um bart
i was gonna say something but i saw you
go i know and i [ __ ] up because i
talked to air at the same time
i know i was going to explain sick as
hell because you just make up words but
anyway it doesn't matter i like zika
zell i know you made it up you know what
i was trying to do but i was like [ __ ]
so i gotta do it on my on my own um i
was at the dmv yesterday yeah and uh so
i picked up a plate finally my license
plate from nevada after how long
appropriate amount of time and i was
about a year in a month fine and then uh
i was like cool i like vegas has a lot
of really cool
um like custom plates or not they're not
even custom because you need them at the
dmv
and uh no no then they're called
i guess they're called vanity plates
sure so i wanted to get one that says
veteran on it and i wanted to get the
marine corps emblem on it because they
actually have it and it's so cool so
they have a emblem for every single
branch every branch oh [ __ ] how many
branches six
uh to my knowledge i think there's four
okay cool cool there's also space force
now so i don't even know sick so um but
people look at it as a joke i don't know
anyways uh i wanted to get wait wait
space force doesn't like men in black
type [ __ ]
i don't know when donald trump brought
it up everyone was laughing at him well
i mean it's donald trump dude i don't
know he was probably like uh i'm going
to get you a via space force
you know so yeah no [ __ ] everyone's
going to lie that's a pretty good
impression
i mean that's how i hear it
but yeah i wanted to get hooties on it
because cause taika loves so many words
man they love saying hooties no you
wanted boom shakalaka before so that i
want a boom shakalaka
but because the marine corps emblem
takes up so much space you can only have
like like a few letters and then you
wanted before that it was something else
um
he just makes up so many words yeah so
now he's like yeah i'm gonna get hooties
and i think he would love it once you
know how it reads but um i needed plates
immediately and it would have taken six
weeks or some [ __ ] yeah so i was like
you know what okay let me just get my
place right now
then online i'm gonna get the hooties
yeah if i know you you're not gonna do
it i'm gonna no you're not you take so
you're like it's on my list you have so
many things on your goddamn list
dumb things that's a dumb thing shoot up
to the top
yeah
shoot up taxes go right to the bottom
it's on my list buying buckets of slime
how many times have i asked you to bring
up a goddamn ladder so i could change
this [ __ ] annoying ass filter the ac
filter because it goes
because i think there's so much gunk in
it that it just like that's coming from
the person that says that they could do
everything in the house all of a sudden
i can i just want to make you feel like
a man sometimes i do feel like a man i i
feel like a man when i tell you to go
bring up the ladder
but that's not men [ __ ] yeah it is you
don't make sandwiches no more yeah as
long as you listen to me as long as you
listen to me what do you mean no more so
that you're saying that there's some
point in time in our relationships when
i would make you sandwiches so i wasn't
good i was a good wife
your chill sandwich is pretty good my
white sandwiches tuna
oh really all i do is add mayo my guy
that's literally all i do
you probably stirred a certain way
i guess my mom is a [ __ ] she puts
jalapenos she puts onion she puts uh uh
uh celery she puts tomatoes celery oh
god i think god i can't wait to see my
mom that [ __ ] could cook love her i was
about to say i'm gonna get mcdonald's
and i was like oh wait i'm gonna die
we are on a diet we're on
week one day five
[ __ ] five
and you've already now two times waiting
but i stayed within my caloric
restrictions for sure yeah for sure but
like we're not made for [ __ ]
bodybuilding competitions no not at all
um but i did have a topic for this
podcast yep and i wanted to bring it up
because i feel like it's something
that's like at the forefront of a lot of
people especially early
uh like mid
adults and then also middle age people
and then also because our demographic is
actually um a lot of people 24 to like
35. that's our biggest demographic yeah
we love it which is crazy because i
think a lot of people hi friends cuz
like sometimes i'll like i'll read the
comments and it's funny like how wrong
the haters have it and they're like why
would you talk about this
like know your fan base and i'm like
yeah
on the analytics
i can see
that over 50
is people 24 to 35 yeah yeah so like
this is very age appropriate um and
that's why i want to bring this up
because um i feel like this is at the
topic of conversation right now
what are some things that you wished you
knew before
about the housing market oh [ __ ] this is
really grown-up [ __ ] yeah and taxes
because you know a lot of stuff like for
us i don't know
go ahead like for us i think a lot of
stuff we learned from crashing burning
trial and error yeah a lot of it or
mainly crashing and burning is the right
way to learn about it yeah um that's the
only way like for example with jk right
we dropped
like what almost half a million dollars
on the jk party and jk new set to know
that it didn't work it didn't work
like that's a [ __ ] a [ __ ] ton of
money you know so now when like when i
talk to uh like newer creators when they
talk to me about stuff about like i want
to increase production whatever like my
first advice i give i give to people now
i go without a
um very honed in
reason on the creative
direction
adding money is the worst thing you can
do you know so like uh like and they're
like oh what do you mean i'm like so for
example and i'll always give our
our example of like jk news i'm like
what made jk news
so awesome is people felt like there
were a group of people in a room talking
about something
and they felt like they're in the room
right so our new set it looks
professional it feels more removed it
feels like it's a talk show so um
although that's what we wanted we want
it to look doper yeah it's
it crushed the magic of what made people
like it yeah and so i always go but so
if we would have dumped money in that
regard maybe putting a camera in the
center or structuring it even more and
make it feel more inclusive yeah that
would probably make it even better you
know yeah so like um i'm having
difficulty answer this question only
because
i always consider like opportunity costs
right so
in retrospect i i'm like well i like the
decisions that i make because one
obviously when you crash and burn
there's a lot of lessons right there's
way more lessons than when you win
right when you win you're like i think
it's because i did this this and this
but when you burn and [ __ ] are
incinerated and [ __ ] turn into ash to
never exist again
that's when you're like oh yeah yeah
yeah you always look you always learn
more when you fail that's what i have to
avoid the next time you know yeah um
so
so
because of that
i'm like i like the way things happen
and i know that's not your question so
that's why i'm saying like it's
difficult for me to answer that
but um
growing up my father was i've never
called in my father
my father you always call me a big daddy
i never call you big daddy i call you
with my little chinito why'd you call me
father right now no my father
my dad
um
he was always drilling in all of his
kids heads by a house by whatever it is
that you like in our office when we got
an office he was like why don't you just
buy the [ __ ] office when we got the
gym he's like why don't you just buy the
property in the gym and i'm like bro if
it was that cheap i would have bought it
but um
it it was never really explained
why right so
um
once you start did you ever ask why
like
yes but and it's like well because now
you own something and it's like okay i
mean i could have came up why do i need
a why do i need to own something well in
case [ __ ] hits the fan now you have that
right but i didn't really understand
like
it's like a
uh it's literally an adult
having an adult conversation with a kid
and forgetting that the kid doesn't know
jack [ __ ] and forgetting to
like he just gave me the synopsis he
gave me the conclusion without really
walking me through
all the different story lines didn't
give you the context fill in the blanks
to help you right help it resonate in
you right so for me i'm like
like duh right like of course if you own
something you can sell it for something
else but it didn't really um
like even like the concept of dying
right like we all know we're gonna die
but we don't really like change our life
because we're gonna die like we don't
try to like expedite anything or try to
change anything in our life we're just
like oh that's just a thing that we know
that's gonna happen yeah
the end so like him saying you owning
property a house or your own business
building um that's really good because
now you own it and you don't have to pay
rent and now it's like it's this thing
that you have i was just like
well yeah
yeah i get that you know but it never
really clicked that you can buy this
thing
at this rate now
and the the prop like the land value
goes up you know like money will go down
but like land never really does
um lan is is a finite uh
uh thing like we're gonna run out of it
like so there's all that time to come up
with the word and usually thought of
thing
um
yeah i guess so because i think i'm just
trying to like figure out what i'm
trying to say
i'm not that smart do you not [ __ ]
understand that i'm not with you what's
the
prime minister's latin word because i
want to make sure i nail it thing
thingamabobber
listen here you [ __ ] i got with you
you know i'm not smart true
so like
when really thinking about it you know
how we like um we we
i can i will speak for myself i come
from like the [ __ ] bottom of the
barrel i didn't grow up with money i
always had [ __ ] desires for a bunch
of material things because i thought
that's just like the cool [ __ ] right
it's like a status symbol
so when we start making money on youtube
and all these other places i'm like yo
i'm just gonna
splurge on all the things that i want i
wanted to live in downtown l.a i wanted
a nice car there's like these material
things because i'm like in my 20s
and i'm like i'm going to experience
those things
instead of really setting myself up for
the future
you know not that like i'm like
struggling by any means now
but could i have made smarter moves with
my money absolutely but then i would
have still had had like these like
that's what i mean by the opportunity
costs where i would have still been like
man but i never really got to live out
the my little fantasy my little dream of
like ooh my little sex in the city life
you know but that dream is only based
off of
um the state of mind that you have 100
yeah 100 but like so if you change the
state of mind you'll have different
dreams absolutely
you know and i think that only comes
with maturity like doesn't our mind stop
developing like in like our mid to late
20s
uh like
biologically building yes
no idea maybe well it does um so a lot
of these irrational things that we do
not to excuse it but it comes from like
an immature
and and you know mind
um so like if i could do it differently
with this mindset
i wouldn't have
made a lot of the moves that i did with
my money like what i would have saved a
lot more
i wouldn't have um
i would have tried to have bought
property immediately
and then from there start buying other
properties
um i would have
i think that would have been the biggest
one picking up way more property for me
it's buying a house as early as i could
yeah so like a couple of like things
that i learned was um
like i don't know why like for some
reason it was pitch to me like this
whether it's like
the
housing real estate or self-help
business gurus of that time or maybe
just the people i was surrounding myself
with
but what was pitched to me is one you
know like when you first start earning
money and you're like you're your own
entrepreneur you're like
just let you know in california you're
gonna get hit with taxes hardcore it
could be anywhere from 30 to 40
so like tax deduction tax deduction is
such a huge concept for most business
owners right so you want to write things
off staplers or like oh if i repaint the
house like that's like or repaint my
business that that's a renovations you
know like you know you buy clothes and
like you can write that off too yeah
you're trying to do things to go okay
cool what can i do to benefit the
business and still like be legally uh
smart financially smart in that way
and so what was pitched is if you rent
you could write off a hundred percent
um if you
pay a mortgage you can only write off
half of the house because you own the
house so if you own the house you
technically can't use all of it for
business because the other half or at
least half of it you're living you're
living in right so with that in mind
okay so you can't deduct as much with
the house as if you rent so you could
deduct 100 just like when you buy a car
versus lease a car you lease the car you
could run off the whole thing you buy a
car you only could uh
uh like right off half until we found
out that later on else depends on the
gross weight of the car does it qualify
as commercial
vehicle like all kinds of crazy stuff
like a g wagon that's why some people
have g-wagons out there
you could deduct the whole thing because
of how heavy it is it's considered a
commercial vehicle
um so because of that i think i've
always just put like a buy later by
later right even though just like you my
mom's like
got to buy something right sounds just
like her yeah if you rent you're
flushing it down the toilet it doesn't
sound like her anymore when you went you
literally she's back flush in the toilet
right she always talks about that like
the money goes down the train yeah
dwayne
and then so like that sounds like a
mixture of paw bear in his mom
and so um so i do have that lurking in
the back of my mind but i'm like maybe
my mom's doing that from her old lands
thought process doesn't know like she's
a [ __ ] dinosaur she knows stupid this
isn't all her strategy stuff right like
the people know these days
and it wasn't until
um
we bought our first house because we
were gonna settle down so it wasn't even
like a strategic thing it was more of a
life move rather than a finance strategy
move and through that life move
i found out um you can because things
get old
uh
the the physical pro the physical
constructs of a house it took you that
long to come up with physical
wow
interesting how that works huh yeah
physical is better than thing at least
has three syllables
you had to [ __ ] think how many
syllables but i didn't think i knew it
you had to look up that's thinking no my
eyes are dry so i was just
resetting them okay sure
you don't know how windshield wipers
work
yeah they go side to side not up and
down what kind of car do you have i got
a new one
what's it called
it's called the mesla
you're the mess like you're a [ __ ]
mess so um
yeah like the physical stuff like wood
gets old metal gets old glass gets old
so you can technically write off the
depreciation of the house
because the physicality of it is
depreciating you can
yeah oh [ __ ] i thought i thought they
only just look oh yeah no [ __ ] that's
why you have to get it appraised so
you're writing off the depreciation of
the house however that's in theory in
real life because
land and homes are a finite thing
see it works over time it only goes up
right so it's a giant loophole it's
you're writing down the depreciation but
it never really depreciates it only
appreciates so that's one huge thing
the other thing i think whatever the apr
or like the interest rate you can write
that off um
and then you can write off half of it
and so like at the end of the day when
you tally up all those things
you technically have an asset now that
has even more tax deductible benefits
than renting and you don't have an asset
and i'm like holy [ __ ] what if i would
have known about this sooner
how long were we were we renting after
we made like sustainable income i don't
know maybe like four or five years i'm
like dude
i feel like we've been moving every year
ever since yeah but i'm like dude we
could have like and we see how much
housing appreciates right i'm like dude
we could have bought a house for like
400 grand 500 would have had a couple of
apartment complexes and that dude could
that that thing could have been like
seven or eight hundred grand and i'm
like dude like so that really uh there's
this real estate phrase and then really
make it ring uh ring a bell in my mind i
really make it ring yeah i really make a
ring in my head
which is they go when's the best time to
buy a house
they say yesterday was the second best
time
yesterday right now
oh they always say that we're not in
sync right now because it'll always go
up and value yep in a straight line if
you zoom out enough it'll always be yeah
we're very cute it'll be a straight line
and i'm like
oh my god that's freaking crazy it's not
bad we're in our 30s you know what i
mean
yeah but you also got these [ __ ]
young cats like graham stefan these days
that are like yeah well he didn't have
[ __ ] they're like let me list out my
ass stupid like by the time i was 21
yeah i had seven thousand i had five
million dollars i don't even know what
to do with it and i'm like [ __ ]
mess
well at least we know tyke is gonna be
set
because taika is gonna learn from like
all our [ __ ] you know what i mean
true so i'm like
and i don't feel like it's bad we're at
by any means i know that's not what
you're saying yeah yeah yeah yeah but
you're just trying to um
you're trying to help
all the other future barts and geos out
there yeah because it's just
obviously i feel like we're in a very
comfortable place
but very cool but any time you learn the
um i wish i woulda knew known
what is going on i wish i would have
known piece of information
it makes you go back like you know and
you start checking all the other things
you're like god i can't do that i hate
doing [ __ ] like that and that's why i
wanted to bring up my opportunity costs
of things but i love doing that you know
why yes because we live in cycles and it
helps you inform the future yeah
because a wise person
said the answers of the future are in
the past residing in the past
yeah
yeah
um
i'm aware of these things i do think
about those things but i don't dwell in
it because i'm like well i got to live a
really cool [ __ ] life
yeah for sure i focus on that too and
like again these failures that aren't
really failures by any means i'm like
cool i don't have to do that anymore
because how many people do we know where
they're like uh we gotta get an office
if we're gonna start a business we gotta
get a [ __ ] office and i'm like fences
first you're gonna start with the
[ __ ] liability already yeah now i'm
good
oh i need to get so many [ __ ] staff
and i'm like are your operations on lock
bro yeah cause if they're not
all these people don't mean [ __ ]
you know like it's just
i i prefer it the way i've done it yeah
yeah it's what i tell myself so i don't
[ __ ] cry every night
but um
yeah at least we know now
yeah
buy
yesterday
buy today if you can yeah
yeah and then also looking at like you
know when you just hear words
when you're like coming when you're like
growing up you hear words you don't want
to know what that means
what words did you hear like [ __ ] a
mortgage
just okay okay just be quiet
right someone goes hey there's mortgages
well the one that always threw me off so
the mortgage i didn't mind but they were
like is that going towards your
principal or towards the interest and
i'm like i don't know what the [ __ ] can
i just pay the minimum payment or the
payment that like what do i got to pay
well i was good at math so i understood
those two things well cool do you know
what they mean now
no i just [ __ ] tell me how much i
gotta pay and i'm gonna put it on
autopay i don't care so principal
is so you know when i loan you money
yeah
if i have a hundred grand
i loan it to you yeah i don't have it
anymore
that hundred grand i could have used
yeah for my own stuff to turn into 200
right
so in order for it to make it worthwhile
for me i charge you interest right so if
i loan you 100 uh let's just for easy
math
based off the interest i would want 150
back yep right yes so the 100
is the principal you're paying me back
the principal amount right the interest
is the additional 50k course
but when you
when you have a more monumentization
yeah
what they do which is smart is when you
pay off uh when you start paying me
like let's say you give me a thousand
bucks i don't count the thousand based
off the principle because i'm charging
my interest based off the principle i go
oh you know what that thousand will go
into the 50 grand so now you still owe
me 49 grand worth of interest plus
the principal yeah and the longer you
take the more interest rides on that
hundred so if it takes you longer the
150 might turn into one six and you can
get penalized if you
aren't reading it correctly and you pay
it before you say or like if they go
like nope you agreed by this time if you
pay a tuner we're gonna penalize you
yeah so that's why the whole umbrella
mormonization thing it's uh
amortization yeah that's why yeah
momenta mori that thing is uh it's so
important
fine amore amore
amores
yeah that's why it's so important um
because it's when you pay things back
like you can pay something for five
years and you go cool how much of the
principal that i paid down and they're
like none because you've only been
paying the interest only yeah
yeah that is a [ __ ] that is a [ __ ]
so i understand that
this episode of get close is brought to
you by zip recruiter
during this summer i have a lot to look
forward to especially since taika is out
of school now so we're going to be doing
a lot more trips especially back to
california so he can hang out with his
cousins and with grandma and if you're a
business owner the last thing you want
to do is to sort through tons of
unqualified candidates resumes when you
could be doing the same thing spending
time with your family and enriching your
child's summer experience and that's why
you need zip recruiter to help you find
great candidates because they do the
work for you at barbara brigade we've
actually found a bunch of former
employees off of ziprecruiter and it's
because they use a powerful technology
to find and match the right candidates
for your job one of my favorite things
that they do
is that you can even easily review
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply so they don't even
have to apply for your actual business
or your company you can look for the
positions that you need and go oh wait
these people got the skills that i'm
looking for i'm gonna invite them to
apply so that's a really really cool
tool and a lot of business owners
if you're at the stage where you can
expand rapidly that's freaking awesome
but from the people that i know most
people are still in that freelance stage
and when you're a freelance stage you're
technically an entrepreneur but you work
for yourself and you don't have much
help whether you're photographer editor
or writer and now it's time for you to
scale your business and you're ready to
hire that first professional to cover
the things that you might not be the
best at or the stuff that you don't
quite want to do zip recruiter is an
awesome resource because you can go
through all the resumes and find a
really really good match for yourself
and if you're on the other end what's
really cool about zip recruiter is since
there's tons of companies that are
always looking for qualified talent just
put your resume on there and who knows
it might not even be the company that
you're submitting or applying for it
could be someone else looking for
exactly for the skill set that you have
and they hire you on so soak up all that
the summer has to offer and let zip
recruiter do the work
go to
ziprecruiter.com get close to try
ziprecruiter for free that's
ziprecruiter.
get close to try ziprecruiter for free
the what i was saying is what i don't
understand is
why that goes that way but then a credit
card which is also alone
includes it all together and because
it's together as you're paying down the
balance the interest is only getting
accrued based on the remainder of the
balance yeah that's what i meant what do
you mean
where where this one it's just it's a
different way that they can you can pay
interest only on a credit card too
you know well you you know the minimum
though the minimum is interest only
so if you always pay the minimum your
balance never goes down
and that's how they win forget that
that's why that's how they win that's
how the credit cards win yeah so they're
literally getting free money from you
for like five years i know and you check
back you're like i've been making my
credit card payments but have you been
paying the balance yeah or have you been
paying the minimum payment which is
interest only maybe i forgot that part
but my mom and my my dad have always
been like just use cash and i was like
bro this is the wave of the future it's
all about the [ __ ] plastic yeah and
now i'm like damn it just keep it
[ __ ] simple stupid who taught you
that it was all about the plastic what
made you go that's the what the [ __ ] how
come you're like speaking in [ __ ] the
black keys right now of the piano
you sound like you're [ __ ] warped
like you're for vocals
you are pretty gross how how what made
you think that um
the plastic was the future now it's the
right way
i think it was just impulses trying to
control it it was convenient yeah that's
what it was you know because i'm like oh
anything your parents did anything my
parents did i'm like that's the [ __ ]
stage coach and [ __ ]
horse stage right there i don't want any
of that stage yeah yeah yeah
like the horses that pull the the stages
yes
you know the stages where the [ __ ]
they're acting fans perform yeah and the
band's performing they pull the whole
thing they're pulling the whole thing
okay um
yeah and then for you with their [ __ ]
rickshaws right so like for me that
those are people pulling them yeah yeah
but those that's just the old method
that's where i'm going with so anything
they did i was like this is so old like
as soon as internet became a thing in my
world
and then i'm like dude i could do this
[ __ ] like i could do banking online they
were like no no no fraud and i was like
yes give it to me give it all to me so
anything that was like convenient i'm
going that route that's a tough deal
with financial literacy
it's like
everyone says this including myself
man i should teach this in school
and i'm like
maybe they did teach it in school but
none of us paid attention they didn't
teach it in a critical they didn't teach
it in
high school because like i got my first
credit card when i was 18. no not for me
don't we take all of us take like
politics or some you know the senior
classes they like they're preparing you
for the real world i didn't get any real
world preparation outside of sex ed
no we we all took like one political
science or one like yeah but that didn't
talk about the financial literacy at all
did you take
econ at all
in college yeah no everyone had to take
some sort of econ before you graduated
like all of us
like we all needed to take some sort of
pe all right you know what it's freaking
a bill right and i just don't think any
of us are even paying attention so
you're telling me everyone that's saying
that
he also didn't pay attention that's what
i'm thinking i'm like you know what
i think we all say look at my i have my
credit i have my uh not my credit cause
i'm like i think we all we all uh um so
look so these are my these are my grades
here and these are the classes i took
okay okay so there's history
there's uh photo there's geometry pe
literature uh what else
american lit american government biology
i don't see any [ __ ] econ dude
pe english science nah i didn't get any
of it
no there's got to be at least one that
like
no i don't see anything on there that's
econ
well anyways they don't they don't it
was history that i was thinking of it's
not econ they don't teach loopholes for
sure or they don't teach like benefits
you know but i i i do think they
probably do they didn't teach credit
card [ __ ] man because i remember i got
my first credit card at like 18 yeah and
it was for 20 000
what yes man that they were handing out
money back for real man and i was just
like when i saw that i was just like
holy [ __ ] did you know the first credit
card i applied for
i got like a thousand bucks
that's crazy yeah it was not it was a
capital one and i have it till this day
maybe i applied like right when the uh
housing market or a recession happened
that's how that's the other thing that
was 2000
remember y2k yeah yeah yeah like maybe
2001 2002. that's the other thing that
um i wish i knew a little bit more in
terms of financial literacy
is like bear markets and bull markets
so cute
what animals but don't mistake it with
like the donkey
or what's the other one the elephant for
the political animals right don't mix
those guys no so like um
learning about those where when one is
like in a state when the economy's in a
state of growth
and it's a [ __ ] bull because of his
[ __ ] balls that's why they [ __ ]
have that [ __ ] big ball bull statue
and uh but the bear is kind of cool too
he seems aggressive they should have put
a ball this guy's not a great look at
his he they got round ears dude true
that's true they got round here
animal like a
like a [ __ ] bunny it should have been
the bull oh there should be a plant
well you said an animal you freaking
a plant that local like a [ __ ]
cucumber ivy
a plant that moves what do you mean like
without the wind
no cucumber iv is a crawl
oh as it grows don't all plants move
then
yeah they all get so stupid
you're such a weirdo like bear and bull
markets yeah and understanding there's a
strategy
on words
bear bear and bear
huh like bear
bear okay like rare bear but yeah it's
bear like as in there's nothing like
it's just like
it's just a bear market like b-a-r-e
bear
oh maybe
were you that [ __ ] lost with bear and
bear yeah
so maybe bear and bull market can't
believe i'm burying this [ __ ]
conversation be quiet
uh where one of them is like uh growing
one of them is shrinking right and
understanding their strategies for both
and not that one's better than the other
but also knowing that it doesn't last
forever so when the housing market is
booming
that's not gonna last forever or if like
unemployment is shrinking
that's not going to last forever or like
inflation like right now our gas prices
are someplace in l.a it's eight bucks
but that's not going to last forever
they don't last forever
but they don't ever go down
that's the thing we're like weird i know
it it'll go down a little bit but it'll
come back up yeah so it never goes down
because i don't see gas being 10 cents
and that's the other thing about
financial literacy is looking at graphs
so when you look at graphs and you zoom
out by decades like 1950 to 2000
whatever everything like economy
everything's going to be a straight line
but when you zoom in really micro that's
when you go like this and you see that
like crazy in crypto right it's like
and the more zoomed in you are like my
heart rate every time i see you
wow you love me that much sometimes
thank you you're welcome so it's like
that volatile you know but then so like
also understanding that we're like okay
there is going to be a phase where like
bitcoin freaking everyone is the raging
about it there's gonna be another time
where no one cares about it and when no
one cares about it that's the best time
to buy because if everything goes up in
value then you'll build equity on stuff
so like almost like what the
what the common consensus is like oh the
real estate's getting cold that's when
you want to buy because by the time it
gets hot it's too late so understanding
those things too and that those cycles
don't last forever is something i wish
they probably taught me which they
probably did
you just missed that whole weekend yeah
they probably there probably was like a
bear bowl i remember even in fifth grade
did you guys have like a mock stock
market no of course not what i'm la usd
baby you didn't teach us [ __ ]
no
i didn't even get home at we had we had
a a mock stock market in fifth uh no
fourth grade that's amazing and what we
did was all the kids would highlight
they bring the newspaper remember you
used to read the stock market in the
newspaper you would bring the stock
portion of the newspaper and i thought
it was so cool yeah and everything you
saw numbers and [ __ ] and i'm like yeah
and every kid highlights like three
stocks or something five stocks
um that they like yeah and then so you
know kids of course doing like coca-cola
or hershey that's the whole point right
like you want to invest in the companies
you believe in yeah and then you tracked
it over time and then at the end of the
like class you see who made the most
money
off of this fake money that you bought
before
no i was just
that's super cool i was probably just
doing a [ __ ] lame ass
[ __ ] poster on like abraham lincoln
or some [ __ ] and like
i was i don't know he's just [ __ ]
tall and you know he's [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] he always hid [ __ ] in his hat he
was six four
yeah he always hid [ __ ] in his hat
that's why his house so tall what kind
of stuff do you hide
you know just stuff like what like
secret stuff i don't know like hangers
papers speeches
money
you just keep [ __ ] in there how does not
fall off
it's a hat it goes on your head like it
does this thing it doesn't just like
how do you wear hats
but they had like shillings back then
doesn't have metal coins they didn't
have paper money when did they create
the paper money
well their paper money is probably this
big so you can't fold paper you have to
roll it up well then he rolled it up
and he probably tied it with the [ __ ]
strings well how do you keep all that
stuff organized in there they're
probably all mixed around
yeah maybe he didn't care do you think
he has a hat organizer like hat dividers
oh wouldn't that be sick yeah they bring
tall hats back and now there's like
slots
and you can put different things in
there yeah like
a tackle box have you seen the memes of
like all the girls uh how we can like
hold a bunch of [ __ ] in our hands so
like we'll be like this in one hand and
then we have keys and our wallet and all
that you haven't seen that like how much
[ __ ] girls can hold oh but i've seen
girls hold a lot of [ __ ] but you know
it's because like we just don't have
pockets yeah yeah the people that could
hold the most are waiters have you seen
waiters especially chinese waiters well
they're kind of cheating because they
have like this big flat plate no i'm
talking about the ones that go like this
oh
yeah
where they have like five different
plates and i'm like holy [ __ ] they're
just walking off at us yeah i think they
[ __ ] need to do a cirque show
restaurant edition
but yeah there is a lot of stuff i wish
i would have known to ask questions
about
i also didn't think i was going to have
well that's not true so also looking
back like that fourth grade uh stock
market class i had i went man that was
cool so it's fourth grade not fifth
grade the fourth grade yeah okay but
then when you're a kid
that's just boring as [ __ ] yeah you
don't know what the [ __ ] any of it means
so i'm like that's i think that's the
gap right like how do you
take useful information and how do you
make it important to people that's why i
like um taika school
because they're teaching you how to
apply it
in the real world right so if your
teacher would have been like hey
um i'm going to create everyone's going
to create a their own their own business
and now you guys the leader of each of
the businesses is going to talk to the
class
and is going to give a speech as to why
we should
give money to this class
right because that's how the stock works
and then and then now it's fun because
now kids are going like oh [ __ ] we got
money and like now all the companies are
trying to like really think of some cool
[ __ ]
to to to deliver to their class so that
they can get this money because whatever
money they get they should keep it or i
mean i think that's illegal in schools
but that money could be turned into like
i don't know they're gonna have like a
pizza party or [ __ ] ice cream float
day or some [ __ ] you know like
incentivize it so that it can mimic what
really happens
you know in rural and real world and if
you want to take it a step further the
money that is they make then they go
okay do you want to reinvest it into the
company or do you want to put it in
savings or do you want to
you know what i mean yeah because and
that's what really does happen that's
the you think that's the key to build
the bridging the gap is
making a game out of it fun yeah
because that's how like you and joe say
that like you see life it's a game and
that's what makes it exciting because
you understand that
no rules are really there
you know like like a game it's like you
can break certain rules and you can be
evolved and become this different
character and you can buy different
things and like
you can like um
uh what does it evolve in this game yeah
and it's
if you can make anything a game if you
can make anything fun
kids are just gonna like soak it up
that's true because how many of those
teachers that made history fun or just
that that topic in school that made it
fun where you're like man i don't even
feel like i'm learning anymore like it
just feels like i'm having a good ass
time and somehow it's like i'm retaining
this i don't know if i had any class
that was like that's fun oh
i had some that are fun like my photo i
mean obviously it's photos so it's gonna
be fun regardless yeah uh
but there's still people that can make
photo boring yeah and it's like this is
how you
develop film you got to get this chlora
whatever and then there's the other ones
that are just like hey let's just [ __ ]
off for a little bit let's try this hey
is that what you're thinking let's try
that and then as you're experimenting
and they go well did you know
yeah i don't i think you can make
anything fun
like that was one of the things i saw
remember that i don't know if i follow
them anymore or what happened but they
grew really big but um uh people of new
york i think it was called mm-hmm
humans of nature oh humans of new york
and they interviewed this dad
he has two sons i think one was like six
and it was like nine or something and he
talked about his savings strategy with
the kids and he would give them
allowance but he would tell them how do
you want to use this you can buy
something now
and get what you want or we can invest
it
he's obviously not investing but he's
saying like but it's going to accrue
interest so whatever money you have
right now if you don't touch it and we
save it
i'm gonna give you another dollar at the
end of the year or some [ __ ] and then
that way he was kind of already
preparing them to invest to save or what
what it's like not to save and get what
you want right away yeah and he was
already like teaching them money
management and i'm like [ __ ] i didn't
have any of this one thing that my mom
really helped me with is she says
whatever money you make always save half
yeah mine said the same [ __ ] too but did
it work no
it worked for me
why would did she explain it is that why
um i don't think she explained it oh you
just weren't stupid like me no i think i
just saw i saw enough examples of when
you don't what happens
oh i've never seen that you know what i
mean thank god my parents are [ __ ]
yeah like really good with money like
even like uh just with the homies like
late high school early college
um
the ones that worked and no one's making
baller money because we're all in early
college right people were like either
lifeguards or they worked at like a tire
shop or whatever but the homies that
like um
you just knew they didn't spend that
much didn't buy new clothes all the time
like it'd be like just weren't that cool
yeah i'm just kidding no no how much you
have saved and i'm like i got like 10
g's i'm like what the [ __ ] because
that's like an absurd amount of money
when you're like 17 or 18. you know even
a grand is yeah i'm like what i'm like
holy [ __ ] and then he was like and i'm
how much money do you make he goes i
might make like 300 bucks or 500 bucks
every two weeks that's so boring it is
boring but they want the shoes right now
i know and they put that away and i'm
like man that's discipline right yeah
and then so that started making me go
like
oh man i should and then it's hard it's
really hard because you you know how
much you make so
when you work that hard you're like i
want to spend all of it i want to enjoy
all of it you know i like how you talk
with your eyebrows yeah you're like oh
yeah like if you got 100 bucks you want
to buy like 99 worth of food like is
that gonna help me get some steak that's
crazy put your eyebrows up and it
literally eats up half of your forehead
i met some guy at the usa peel
nationally he has a smaller fork no i
don't believe i swear to god i'll show
you is the back of his head really big
i'll show you his instagram i was like
what i think i got beat finally
no
his forehead is smaller than mine right
now you have a two head dude this guy
has a one head i have like a five head
but you have a two head you have so much
room for receding hairline i know and
your dad and your mom both have really
great hairlines so you are [ __ ]
fortunate yeah i mean your hairline's a
little groovy but it's all good but and
i think also seeing my mom uh with her
measly little salary i think when she
first started working she's only make
like i don't know 30 grand a year or
something i've seen her buy multiple
houses yeah and then pay them off
you know and i see how frugal she is
and then seeing how like
i mean my mom's taking a millionaire
with the assets she owns
but
she's like like that book right
psychology of money in no way shape or
form did she have one of the baller
occupations she wasn't a a lawyer or a
doctor
she just worked at like a corporate
nine-to-five job right yeah and then
that clocked in and clocked out and then
did the traditional thing where if you
need a little bit more money you try to
get a little more overtime that's
technically my mom too then yeah and
then she
yeah your mom's a millionaire too and
then um she might even be a
multi-millionaire but just over time
you know and then
uh but seeing how she lived
and i'm like wow that is the power of
saving like
not buying every single thing that you
want and living
way under your means has so much power
and value
yeah
right
it does it really does and i think um
and then also with me like um
i had to test it out of course
where um
i wanna like ball out right so like even
with the porsche
uh when i first got the porsche like
when jk was still making like decent
money it was way under my means like i
always stuck to it but it was also
um
like three times the amount of a car
payment that i'm used to like the
porsche was i think like 1300 bucks a
month right i'm used to like 300 bucks i
like how you're humble you're like when
jk was still making decent money
i'm like jk's still making decent money
what are you talking about then when it
first started making decisions oh gotcha
because there's a lot of period of time
where we're playing each other's 500
bucks yeah yeah yeah yeah we barely
lived i mean barely could have survived
i see i see you missed that part of your
sentence when we first started making
decent money got it um
the
and it was way under my means because we
had so many revenue streams already
but even 1300
every month seeing that get deducted
from my bank account it hurt um
it would be like a mini heart attack
right i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah that's true
but it's also one of those things where
i feel like sometimes you have to go
through it like i got a sick car
and then even with the audi uh r7 that
was a sick car
but now i have my truck and my payments
are 300 bucks a month and it's like i'm
like man money really doesn't dictate
happiness
but it's also you kind of have to go
through it some people yeah yeah for
some people because then it's easy for
people or else people will be like easy
for you to say you have it but once i've
walked through it i truly now understand
what they say where it's like money
doesn't really bring you happiness you
know now my truck is 300 bucks a month
way less than 1300 and at that time i
had two cars
and i only have one car right now and it
makes me so happy to drive that's true i
forgot you had two cars
we had three cars amongst two people
and we're probably on the
on the verge of getting the fourth car
remember we're just looking at cars and
then we're like i always [ __ ] get
that [ __ ]
yeah
yeah and a lot of that has to do with
eagle too you know
um a lot of it is for sure ego because
you're like you're proving to i don't
know who yourself your parents your
colleagues to someone or society child
childhood demons
society or amongst your group of people
if you're like the minority amongst
these people and going yeah [ __ ] that
you know like i proved it to myself that
i'm like an equal where it's like you've
always kind of been an equal dude like
yeah no one's even looking at you like
that bro um and we live in a heavily
well we're also products of social media
right like where it's like everyone has
this flex not that we've ever been
flexed type of people but i'm sure it
influences our decisions
you know
um
but i had like you i the influence is
much bigger
yes whereas like back in the day
it was like just your immediate circle
or whatever you have access yeah it's
the richest dude on the street or
whatever's on tv or the happiest dude on
the street or the the then whatever you
know the nicest lawn on the street is
what you compare to yeah but now
something about the jones is what we
used to call it now in a second you can
see millions of people's front lines
yeah
yeah
um
that so we're products of that too yeah
so like um like you
i needed to live through it too to be
like whoa this is this is not me
and it's really rad to like
um go through that and then say oh [ __ ]
this is this is who i am or money
doesn't buy happiness or these things
are the things that are important and
it's like i knew these things in the
back of my mind
you know but i think that like that poor
kid different yeah i think that poor kid
that like was that felt deprived of the
material things yeah because i never
felt deprived of like family or love
you know
um could it could those things have been
better yeah but like i never felt like i
like i was like
uh
an unwanted thing
you know i didn't feel that was unwanted
but i definitely felt that
it could have used a little more love
yeah but even then you said you still
felt love right
i felt i mean well i felt love when i
got my ass beat yeah i know it wasn't
out of like
alcoholism or just like destroyed abuse
just straight abuse it was out of a good
place yeah um so i felt love there but
after my i got my ass beat it didn't
have
i mean aspie is not my love language of
course i mean you don't feel as beating
and a hug don't feel the same yeah yeah
um
but
how do i
that's why i'm saying like
that that's what i grew up here my
parents say like i do and i work and i'm
becoming who i am now so that you don't
have to do these things you know that's
why school was such an important thing
for my parents because i think they
didn't have that
that luxury of just saying yeah that's
what i'm gonna do
like i don't have to worry about making
a living i don't have to worry about
surviving or anything
so i'm gonna do college so because they
saw that as because remember college
back in the day was a huge thing and it
was just for
the elite
you know they came from that background
so then for to see for them to see their
kids go through it they're just like oh
[ __ ] that's the top tier now
you know yeah so like um
yeah just the like having lived it and
and like i understand where it comes
from it it would have been nice
um to have had that guidance but that's
why i'm like fortunate now that we
understand these things and now we know
tyke is going to be way better than
where we're at which is sick because
that's the goal right like you do want
the next generation to evolve and be set
yeah the the next like
going back to like the housing market
thing like one thing that i was like man
this is really cool that um
as a young adult i'm still i'm like
privileged enough to like when are you
considered an old adult
or does it go just adult
i think young adult is what early 20s
yeah
so you're just an adult bro
you're about to hit 40.
so i was a middle-aged man
is that 50
oh i don't even know anymore we're old
but like also knowing that like um
understanding that when you get a loan
that uh interest rates
fluctuate
maybe not monthly but it could be
quarterly yearly
by decade it can go up and down and so
the same
price of the house your monthly payment
could be way lower or way higher
and but people don't you get a fixed apr
i mean i know there's some people that
don't get it but that's usually what's
offered so it doesn't change it does
your apr like right now it's six percent
when you buy in right oh yeah just
buying if you buy it a year ago or two
years ago it was like three percent so
you're just talking about buying
yeah oh okay okay my bad i thought you
were talking about if you're a home
owner
and then the rates fluctuate because
i'm saying like got it when the interest
rates fluctuate yes that's what i'm just
saying interesting
your credit card depends on the economy
what the fed dictates your interest
rates in general fluctuate yeah the the
period of time
who knows yeah could be monthly could be
quarterly could be yearly but like all
the people that when they when the feds
cut the interest rate hardcore uh during
the pandemic all the people that took
advantage of it
are smooth sailing for 30 years because
you're locking this thing in right so
how many people did we know that
refinance during the pandemic and then
they brought it down from whatever they
had it down to like close to a three
percent or even under yeah and they get
to keep that for 30 years which is
amazing because the same house like
let's say you buy a house it's 500 grand
having it at a two percent interest rate
versus a five percent interest rate
could mean like a couple grand
difference and what does refinancing
even mean
yeah exactly like you know what what
does that mean it's like learning about
what that means right
um and then there's all that yeah cash
out refi
you know like there's like uh
understanding all of that and then even
when you get the loan
um they always recommend twenty percent
down or also you peop the the the word
on the street is because you don't wanna
have the pmi which is morgan insurance
but sometimes it's worth it sometimes
it's worth putting less down so you have
more capital and then the pmi might be
really small might only be 100 bucks a
month
but like really looking into all the
different loans that are available and
really understanding versus just
taking what's given and i think that's
the beauty of the internet like these
days i think it you can become
very well versed at anything yeah if you
want to right where's back in the day
it's like man where do you even go the
bank yeah now you have tax influencers
yoga influencers like dog washing
influence like for every single aspect
of your life there's an influencer
that can help you so much
and you can like uh whereas before like
you need like i don't even know who to
talk to yeah i mean well you don't even
have that access like like me for
example if the internet didn't exist as
i grew up i'm just stuck to my home
yeah or that street that i live on yeah
and like i don't know that there's
anything beyond that yeah
so like um one thing i would recommend
everyone to do
is whatever or if you are getting into
the housing market or anything like that
whatever they tell you research all the
terms that are on there even the stuff
that you think you know look into it
because there's a way more options out
there yeah is there like a place that
you would go to
yeah so like one person that really has
been uh opening up my mind is thatch we
had him on this show he's freaking
awesome he's a real estate mogul
and uh he talks about like all kinds of
stuff like he talks about hard money
lending i don't even know what the hell
that means bro but it's cool because
then he says it he mentions it he gives
good context in the 60 seconds of like
how it plays then i take all those words
that i've never heard before and i
google them and i search them
you know like that's how i found out
like uh how interest rates can dictate
your mortgage i learned about pmis
um
another person i really like is i
believe it's called what's mortgage his
name is min like he takes all these
fancy numbers and he gives you the
in-betweens
and then another person i like um it's i
think it's called uh
i think she's called your rich bff do
you follow her you should she's awesome
i apparently i think she's 25. wow she's
already a multi-millionaire
um so that's what she called you a rich
bff and so she'll say the state of the
economy the interest rates and like how
things are going in different markets
and she goes but what does that mean to
you i love it and it should go okay so
how unemployment is tying into the
crypto space and how it's time so just
like there's so many of these people
that now you have a wealth of knowledge
at your fingertips because um
you when you make financial decisions
you're usually focused on your own goal
i need a house for my family and i want
to grow up but that's
that's the purest way to make a decision
but it's the worst way to make a
financial one because you zoom out and
you go oh wait oh wait dude you're a
veteran did you know there's va loans
you can do that or did you know you
could do this or you know there's like
if you zoom out more you're
accomplishing the same goal but a more
strategic way yeah and that's what i
learned i think ultimately is the more
you can research more and not just take
what people tell you yeah you could find
the smartest way to accomplish what you
want
um
and and without like uh burdening
yourself too financially yeah
i mean i feel like that's just always
been the way since the beginning of time
but now it's just more accessible
because of the internet so now there
should be like little to no excuses
right then why did we [ __ ] up so hard we
had the we're we're on the internet but
when we started those type of
influencers were so little yeah yeah it
was just literally comedy beauty
all the cat all the cat videos couple of
fitness
you know but the in this day and age
it's like man if you want to get in
shape
it takes like a week of scrolling and
you can compile a lot of information to
help you get in shape now yeah
yeah
that is cool
it is really cool there is no excuse
anymore
yeah i thought i was going to sneeze
really hard right now
did it go away yeah
that's so weird i wish i could do that
my sneezes never go away if i have a
sneeze it's coming out no matter what no
matter what it's like busting nuts
like once i get to that point that's it
no turning back you don't even gotta
touch it no more the [ __ ] thing's
oozing oh god why do you gotta call it
ooze cause it's like a toaster strudel
oh man i haven't had that in a long time
i'll give it to you
keep your [ __ ] icing and feeling to
yourself dude
especially when you wear those [ __ ]
headphones your head looks so funny
you know how many times i try to keep
myself from laughing
it just looks so dumb but what's cool
now is um now that i the more i know
the more questions i ask yeah of course
so even like you know you asked like
better questions yeah so like even when
we got um
uh taika taika and we put them in school
i was like you know like when you're
doing on the job training to be better
that school like it's like let's say i
go to take comedy class because i have a
comedy channel that's a tax deductible
it's education right so i'm like is
taika school
tax deductible
and he said no
i was like [ __ ] why would you think it's
tax deductible i don't know but it's
good but now i ask right so now i so now
i learn to ask because
the rule book has already been written
so if you want the the rule book has
already been written but you're not the
one taking advantage of it then you're
not doing yourself any service well
right now we so you know like up that
tick tock trend i'm sure you don't
because you're a boomer but you know
that tick tock tick tock trend where
it's like what's something in your
industry that you know uh that you think
should be illegal or something like that
oh that one uh and there's one where
like this chick she's in finance and
she's like well you could be paying your
kid
about 1200 a year and then that's a tax
write-off and then she goes into
explaining how that goes i mean we knew
that but like
[ __ ] like that stuff like that it's like
why isn't that illegal why is that legal
it's like dude who cares you could have
been doing that less
like this you could have been paying a
couple grand less taxes if you would
have just filed your kid as just like
shuffling paperwork you know there's
just so many rules out there it just
feels illegal right but it's not because
it's not of course but it feels because
they created the laws already you're
taught
you're taught as a as a consumer
right like you only know the consumer
rules but then when you become an
entrepreneur those are some those are
different sets of rules that's when
they're calling people out like
celebrities or like these high profile
people and they're calling them out on
like uh like the taxes that they paid
and this and that it's just like but you
don't understand how business works
we're not understanding because
i think even as a consumer
just knowing rules in general regardless
of your status or financial state it's
going to be so helpful yeah and i'm not
justifying any of the movements of
whatever happens right because some of
these things are [ __ ] shady but
it's like but if the i mean like i don't
know how all this [ __ ] works but you can
have like these [ __ ] paperwork
shuffling that makes it you keep more of
your money
and it's out there
it is out there it's very accessible
information so that's why i ask there's
i ask questions all the time now like
you don't remember like the first time
that i was informed that like uh we can
like write off uh some of the taxes for
taika yeah the next thing i did i was
like what about our dogs
and then our financial survivors like no
you can't ride off your dogs and i was
like and even and then now i learned to
to not even stop there i go why not
and they're like oh because i think in
the actual
legal writing it needs to be a conscious
being
but you can leave your
all your assets and belongings to a dog
then i should ask more questions i don't
know uh maybe i just made that up
but maybe that dog has a power of
attorney that's a human being you know
there's just all these [ __ ] things
now yeah that like as you lear as you
grow you just learn about stuff like
even like power of attorney right i'm
like i love how profound that statement
was what as you grow
you learn about
more stuff like yeah because i'm like
i'm at the dmv right you're not doing
growing and learning stuff
more of it
then you're [ __ ] up yeah okay
like i'm at the dmv i'm like tom cruise
doesn't come here yeah how does he do it
i remember that that was years ago we
were like tom cruise isn't at the
[ __ ] dmv oprah's not here how the
[ __ ] did they do it and then that's when
i found out about power of attorney you
can assign someone to be like your
signer and make calls for you and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm like man
they need to have a [ __ ] like
not call it loopholes one-on-one but
like how to like maximize the law class
or something yeah you know just go
without having to be a lawyer
mean there's that many that
and it varies by city and state
but yesterday i just found out
in the state of nevada
if you're a veteran
you can go to the assessor's office and
you never have to pay a car registration
ever again
and i'm like what
and it was only because the person
across from me
was a veteran
so they saw my license and they're like
did you know you can do this
and i'll and then it would save you a
couple hundred bucks every year
and they i've been doing it for like 10
years or something like that and i'm
like
this is just by the stroke of luck
you know because it is because most of
you don't look into any of this because
most most people at the dmv they already
want you to get the hell out of there
they're not nice to you well out here
they're pretty nice okay well fine well
this guy really oh this lady was really
nice and she's just
a veteran and so she helped me and she's
like you better do it how cool i was
like give it to me give me the paper and
she go it's so fast no one's ever at the
office cause no one takes advantage of
this because nobody [ __ ] knows and
i'm like i know
there's so many cool things out there
that i'm like man you just gotta
you gotta like whenever you hear
something ask three more questions and
just research those things
as ludicrous as can i write off meatloaf
breaking and fun
and then they'll say no and i'm like all
right at least now
i tried
you know
yeah here's some good ask more questions
yeah
because i was trying to write my mom my
mom's ass off
and then my mom and then the the
my financial advisors like that's a
tricky situation
because now that she's a grown-up
if you write her off then that means
you're paying her
and then so that means that's on her
papers is classified as income
it can [ __ ] her [ __ ] up
and so i'm like cool i'm like as i ask
more questions i'm getting a clearer and
clearer picture of things you know yeah
which is pretty cool
that is cool
yeah get yourself with the person that
knows finances
not really because everything like you
said is on youtube it's online yeah but
like ask questions you know
and then ask questions as much as you
can both legally financially
and especially and i want to bring it up
because of the housing market and a lot
of the people that follow us are at that
age mid 20s
early 30s
and they're looking to settle down
and and highlighting the fact that um
like you mentioned earlier on in this
episode
about the housing or the land value is
finite
so it's not going to get cheaper so if
you're going i'm just going to wait
until the time is right it's like no
it's never going to be right because you
can save but you're not going to be able
to catch up on the saving
compared to how fast it's growing or
getting expensive and what's crazy is if
you [ __ ] hate people
did you know that certain places the
state
is incentivizing people to develop land
yeah
so some places they'll pay you yeah
they'll pay you like in the middle of
like utah or like texas or somewhere if
you go hey you know what i'm gonna like
homestead this place or whatever they'll
give you some crazy benefits where you
might even like not even have to come
out of pocket to build the house that
you want yeah there's just so many cool
things out there man there's a ton and
if you're trying to save like i think we
ran into
um trailer park tick tock
we're like yeah they're like i don't
know why people talk down on trailers
but it's so sick and then she gave us a
tour of her trailer yeah she got a
three-bedroom place sick it was like 500
a month yeah and it looked good it was
really good yeah you can't even tell
that it's not a house it looked like a
straight up single family home from the
inside it was beautiful because it was
like um like a farm style
house like really cute yeah
i mean the more you know right
oh nothing i learned okay you know
people been doing this whole van life
stuff yeah no rvs yeah you can get a
mortgage on them what so now like if you
go a mortgage yeah so people they're
like that are like um oh man i really
want a van life
um but it costs so much i see these
builds sometimes they're like 70 grand
or 80 grand i don't got that kind of
money to build it but i really want to
do it
since it's considered like a like a
dwelling
you can get a mortgage like a 20-year
mortgage or a 10-year mortgage on it so
now the payments aren't that bad that's
crazy you know because it's like they
were able to muscle out the [ __ ] car
oh cause you got stuff to get the car
loan but now you have a car loan and a
mortgage no you just get a mortgage for
the van oh because it's already done
it's done yeah yeah yeah see whoa
they don't tell you these things no but
i'm glad you just did
damn let's van life it yeah no mortgage
though yeah you get mortgage on it and
so the payments it might like
over 20 years 30 years or 20 years is
not that much you know yeah and also um
last one of my closing thoughts mine at
least is uh
don't get more [ __ ] if you have a bunch
of debt
like i like
going to sleep at night knowing that
i have very minimal debt like i have i
carry no credit card balances i don't
have paid off any student loans like any
loan that i have i paid off and it
is so comfortable
sleeping at night because i'm not i
don't have these things looming
so like that was one thing that i did
learn in my 20s at least
um was that
yeah just carrying these balances and
like the the idea of like having this
late payment now it's going to ding your
credit and if your credit's all [ __ ]
up then it's a looming mentality yeah
like you can't you can't get a business
loan you can't buy a house you can't get
a car like there's so many things that's
that are tied to this credit score that
i'm just like i want none of it like i
will just wait for anything material i
just want to pay it all off
and now i like whatever money is in my
hand in my bank account is mine yeah i
don't owe anybody
if i can't afford it i can't buy it you
have this rule of three you're out
you're like
if i can't buy three of those things
right now with the money that i have in
my account then i cannot afford it i'm
like i love that when it comes to like
money management i have the dave ramsey
school of thought are you familiar with
with him uh what's his school of thought
so he's like um older like but very like
straight shooter like no [ __ ]
and i like it because although it might
not be the most financially strategic
i think it's practical i think it's very
practical because i don't think the
regular person is like
i aspire to be a billionaire i mean most
people are just like i just want to be
well off and not have finances be
a source of stress and i think he hits
that hard core yeah so his first number
one thing is you have to do things in
this order
don't even invest or any of that
[ __ ] until number one zero debt
right that's his first number one i love
it the second one is have uh
uh anywhere from six
to nine months of living expenses i love
it in an emergency fund practical so you
have so one you have no debts you're not
in the negative then the other one you
have for a rainy day covered yeah then
you have uh you can the first thing you
should invest in
is a mortgage i don't know the first
thing you should uh invest in is
your retirement account because a lot of
times those are tax deductible so you
want to make sure you're maximized in
that area first
where where your first investment can
actually go um
can uh write off some of your taxes then
you go into housing and when you get
into housing make sure
that
your
your mortgage
is only a third to a quarter of your
total income
so if your mortgage is like three grand
your household income
better be
like nine grand or above you know so
it's helpful to be in a household
because you have more combined income
but you got to be like that and then so
that way it's almost like uh i think
statistically it shows it's like 90
fail proof yeah um
versus because some people might tell
you and like you know all the people
that want people to buy crypto at
bitcoin
they don't know everyone's contacts like
oh do you have to get it at what point
in life they're in yeah like oh you got
to get bitcoin so you might have a guy
just coming
just coming out of med school single and
he might be 200k in debt already
trying to like scrounge up money to buy
bitcoin because it's the future but i'm
like you're you're literally trying to
row a boat while there's a hole in it
you know yeah like get rid of that 200
because if bitcoin is popping now yeah
just like how the dot com boom was
popping at one point there's always
gonna be the popping thing so don't have
fomo
like just get rid of that hole once you
plug that hole up the boat's gonna roll
fast you know yeah
yeah and i think you bring up a good
point about um just simplifying a lot of
things because the way you're explaining
it is very simple and it's digestible
yeah right but then we can get caught up
on the terminology and then like the all
these other things but it's like well
what is your plan is your plan to feel
stress free
is your plan to provide for your family
cool let's start from there fine how do
we do that don't just stop there but how
do we do that what's the plan what are
the steps that you take and i love those
steps because they're so
practical yeah you don't have to have a
college degree you don't have to have
financial um crazy financial knowledge
like a [ __ ] masters and above degree
you know to understand this stuff it's
literally
if you have debt pay that off cool the
next step to that is going to be now we
can start saving okay cool once we can
start saving you know like it's it's it
should be simple oh and someone else i
like
is minority mindset
and he's coming on jk news oh super cool
super cool you guys have a bunch of cool
guests on jk news i can't wait to go
back yeah i don't know when i'll go back
but i want to i want to make a little
cameo he'll be on
next thursday
if you want to show up on thursday
i don't know i'll surprise you maybe
um we need to get taco back he crushed
no he just talked about butt all day i
was like but he learned new words now
fine
boom shock a lock of [ __ ] yeah hootie
whoops
did you just boot out of it
he loves that i was just making a joke
of like ways he could say that he didn't
fart and you know yeah that's all he
says he goes mom i just
tooted out of my boot
anyway
thank you guys so much for listening i
hope you guys got a lot of really useful
things from this episode um we love
sharing all of our fails in hopes that
you guys don't have to fail the way we
did and can like evolve and progress way
faster than we ever have don't drop
almost half a million dollars on a
stupid ass set
you don't let just understand your brand
first before you do that let us make the
mistakes
for you guys we'll drop the cash for you
guys um thank you so much for listening
and we'll see you guys next week